[Music]
vertex ai is an end-to-end platform for
machine learning development and
deployment
it includes a suite of new products and
services to support mlaps
i'll introduce some of the key pieces
vertex pipelines feature store and model
monitoring
the backbone of the vertex mlaps story
is vertex pipelines
which lets you automate and orchestrate
your machine learning workflows
vertex pipelines is scalable serverless
and cost-effective
and supports gcp standard enterprise
security controls
you can focus on specifying your
pipelines without worrying about
infrastructure
and you pay only for the resources that
you use
when pipelines execute run metadata is
automatically logged
this allows lineage tracking
reproducibility comparisons across runs
metrics visualization and more let's
take a quick look at how these pipelines
are defined
vertex pipeline supports two easy-to-use
python sdks
kfp and tfx pipelines are built using
reusable components
and many pre-built components exist
including those for
vertex ai services here we're building
an automl
image classification workflow we'll just
compile this pipeline
and run it right from the notebook like
this
then we can view the running pipeline in
the console ui
while the pipeline is running or after
it is finished you can view the pipeline
step logs
and generated artifacts and metadata and
if you want to build your own components
this is easy to do as well automating
orchestration is not the complete
picture though
one common set of pain points revolves
around feature engineering
feature reuse and sharing serving
features at scale
and with low latency and avoiding
training serving sku
the vertex feature store helps solve
these problems it reduces the cycle time
of ml deployments by making it easy to
share
discover and serve features at scale
after you've trained
evaluated and deployed your model you're
not done you still need to pay attention
to the performance of your model over
time
if model drift occurs it may be
necessary to retrain or tune the model
vertex model monitoring helps with both
alerting and diagnosis
you can set up a monitoring job for a
deployed model and get alerts when there
are anomalies
you can configure monitoring objectives
for model features and get distribution
stats
you